[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
توجد مشكلة جهير حقيقية في الهواء
في العديد من المهن ونحن متفقون
لا تخبرنا أنه لا توجد مشكلة
من لديه مشاكل في التوظيف
طالما أننا لا نقدم
زيادات الراتب
هذه الضربة اليوم وأنا هنا
لدعمهم بشروط
زيادة رواتب العمل
شدة جاذبية اليوم
وظيفتهم بسبب
حتى الآن كان هناك عدد قليل
انتصارات في أماكن قليلة ولكن
ذلك لأن القتال يؤتي ثماره
على سبيل المثال في طاقة
زيادات في الراتب لكنها ضرورية
أن كل شخص يحصل على نفس الشيء
لا ينبغي أن يكون محجوزًا لـ
البعض وعلى وجه الخصوص
الراتب الذي لا مفر منه نحتاجه كثيرا
زيادة الراتب من المنع
الأسعار ولكن الزيادات في الأجور
أجر ثابت يقع كل
الشهر الذي لا يعتمد على قسط أي
ليست عشوائية وهذا هو السبب
أن لدينا الكثير